so i got into a netflix donkey series
and this is the story of how it all
happened
how after years of work i thought i was
finally gonna get my 15 minutes in the
limelight
bask in the warm glow of true internet
fame netflix fan
instead i got one second one second that
is unwatchable
and i don't mean like unwatchable in the
metaphorical sense
like an amy schumer special is
unwatchable no i mean
literally unwatchable if you go to the
docu-series
on netflix called money explained the
first episode is about gibberish quick
schemes
you could watch all of it you will not
find me anywhere that's because you know
that little auto play bar where it like
automatically plays the next one so you
don't have to you like watch the credits
and all that like the last five seconds
10 seconds i'm
after that you literally have to do what
no human on earth has ever done
and choose to watch the credits and you
will see
less than a second of coffeezilla uh
featured there and this is the story of
how that happened because let me tell
you i thought i was heading up in the
world guys
and by the way i'm i'm not trying to be
ungrateful like i think i just think
it's funny
i'm gonna put as seen on netflix in my
bio i'm gonna wear it loud and proud
baby but i wanted to tell you guys about
it because otherwise you're going to be
confused you will never
see me on netflix unless you
deliberately go search this out
so really this is my only proof of this
happening so i kind of have to put this
out there before i put as seen on
netflix otherwise people are going to
think
i'm making it up and lying right so
several months ago like eight months ago
at this point i get hit up
by the people at vox the people who make
money explaining they say hey look we
love your channel
we're doing a thing on get rich quick
schemes and we think you've got the
goods we'd love to talk to you
i say great yes let's set up a little
meeting we're chatting it up
i i'm giving them the goods i say this
is who you need to talk about you got to
talk about christani you got to talk
about tai lopez you got to talk about
all these guys
and they say awesome we want to
interview you for our show
and i say hmm let me think about yes
actually yes i
i could fit that into my very busy
schedule so i'm excited and you know
they're sending me releases
and look it's not going to be like
life-changing or anything i didn't even
know how big this show was
at the time i thought it was smaller
turns out it's huge which that's cool
um so missed opportunities okay it
happens to the best of us
but anyways they start sending me
releases you know i send them my home
address we're gonna film everything
we've got all these like questions
specked out and we are uh
two days away i think from the actual
interview
t-minus two days and all of a sudden i
get
uh email in my inbox and they say yeah
um we ran this up to flagpole to legal
and they said like
you are what we call fancy language a
liability
and i was like right i kind of knew that
i mean i
i sort of told them that up front they
said no no we could include you for sure
and then they ran it up legal and they
were like yeah actually
we can't have you on this show but then
i discovered the powerful
force of pity and i said well
am i not going to be part of any of the
show like we've done all this stuff all
this prep work
and i think they um i think they felt
very bad for me and i said good you
should
and so they gave me a like a credit in
the show
even though i appear nowhere so that's
my appearance is
at 2214 you will see my name
coffeezilla in the credits that is all
that is left of me
after legal took a look at it they said
no
we can't talk about anything because and
let me explain that by the way
we talk about a lot of ongoing gurus
things that are happening
now scams that are happening now legal
people don't like that
if you're gonna say something's a scam
they want it to
already be prosecuted done dusted
charged
you have to be very careful when you're
talking about somebody
who has not been charged who's running a
scam in places like netflix it turns out
don't love calling people out like that
and this is not a failure
on their part it's just what it is it's
just the game that they play
and so i think they just realized like
this guy's gonna be a massive liability
he's talking a lot of trash
about people like grant cardone tai
lopez
all these guys that have not been
officially prosecuted by the united
states government yet to which i would
say
what's the point after they have been
right like if you're talking about
bernie madoff after bernie madoff has
done what bernie madoff has done
you're kind of late who are you gonna
help by saying oh yeah we should have
known all along right
but look the point is i get it that's
why
they couldn't include me and from that
point on they basically did their own
thing they made
uh their program on garage quiz schemes
which by the way i do
think got a lot of things right i think
it's worth watching
i really enjoy the production value that
they go through they do a lot
in 22 minutes they cover like every
possible get rich quick scheme
i definitely think it's worth a watch if
for nothing else to watch the credits
and see you boy
okay but when i started getting messages
from my audience being like hey have you
seen the show
have you seen this money explained i
wanted to be like yeah i'm in it
or kind of in the smallest possible way
and even one of my twitter followers
said it looks like you consulted on this
show like
like he suspected that he had no idea
and so yeah i just thought it was a kind
of cool story
i i want to be super clear if i wasn't
already this is not sour grapes i'm not
upset with netflix or vox like they
couldn't be nicer
and that's the funny thing everyone i i
interacted with was
so nice i almost hesitated putting this
out because i was like i don't want to
bring them any
bad attention i do think it's worth
watching but i just thought it was such
a great
hollywood moment uh for how all that
happened i think it's funny that i
thought i was gonna get this and instead
i got
one second of uh fame so don't go
tweeting netflix or vox saying stolen
valor coffee's
no it's fine they did a great job
anyways they didn't need me
and if anything i'm just grateful they
put me in for that one second so i could
tell you this silly little story about
how all this happened
and it's a fun little easter egg you
know so yeah that's basically it
hope you enjoyed this little story i'll
see you guys in the next
smell the one
[Music]